hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
moins vite sur messenger bon bout de
temps à pau va rejoindre jean michel
maire donc je rappelle que jean michel
mr a été un petit peu puni 1 voilà parce
qu'il s'est mal comporté jean michel
maire drapeau
le pauvre jean michel maire sans rigoler
voilà là attendez je vais aller le voir
aller le voir
jean-michel jean-michel commentant des
appareils et à 11 ans le voyage
le bond de télé mais quand je dis
minutes de délai en fait ça va
jean-michel jean-michel jeu à fond là je
paye ma dette je paye ma dette je paye
ma dette à la société
bravo jean michel m'arrêter des voitures
aussi qui passe né à fond dedans
bah oui mais mahut m'engueule arrêté une
voiture voilà maintenant qu'il est
vraiment fatiguant va se retrouver là
l'instant on va le laisser continuer
jean michel maire qu'est ce qu'il a
regardé le jeu est arrêté une voiture la
chambre michel
ap
[Applaudissements]
l année qui vous allez sco vient de voir
c'est une histoire de sadisme